in this country they don't need more dog
trainers they need somebody who trained
the humans so they can rehabilitate the
dog so I created my own job I didn't
really dwell on that one you know for me
like bankruptcy wasn't a big deal
money is not a big deal for me I think
people think I have this gif I'm a
Superman or something and it's not I'm
just like anybody else I'm just very
aware of my emotions you see so I
learned to manage my emotions need
motivation watch a top 10 with belief
nation what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out onto the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew in today's lessons from a
man who went from growing up on a farm
in Mexico and working with animals and
crossing over into the US border at age
21 speaking zero English to becoming a
New York Times bestselling author and
creator of the dog whisperer brand
he's Cesar Millan and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success enjoy
[Music]
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one create your own job as an
immigrant you look for opportunities and
so creativity is part of necessity or
necessity as part of creativity so I
said well you know in this country they
don't need more dog trainers they need
somebody who trained the humans so they
can rehabilitate the dog so I created my
own job yes I couldn't compete with the
other guys because I didn't have papers
in the first place so I needed to open
my own job you know and that's when
people start saying you know that guy
has something going on that's that's
when the LA Times came and say you know
Will Smith as your client MBA people are
you crying FA and I fell people are your
client what would you like to do next
and I say I would like to have my own TV
show so she wrote it down and the the
newspaper came on a Sunday but Monday
was a line of producers outside I wanted
to know what this show is all about it
was about training people and
rehabilitating dogs rule number two is
take control of your life in the
beginning I didn't manage my career it
was managed by somebody else so I went
into a lawsuit and I was not in control
of my own you know intellectual things
you know and so it so I'd realized that
so that's the beautiful part about you
know the what I went through that I
realized that I was not really leading
that side of my life yeah I was pretty
much a follower
which I've been I find out that a lot of
I got a lot of guys in Hollywood's go
through it you know they don't really
own the intellectual property yeah and
so that was a great thing and from that
point on I learned ok so I have to
pretty much understand that I have to
lead that were all as well yeah you know
in order for therefore for me not to
have that experience again and so I went
back I went all the way to back
bankruptcy I already knew how to be
without money right so it wasn't a big
deal for me that I was all ready to be
sure was taken off at this time and yeah
yeah everything was gone I have no money
Wow zero money I have this popularity
and I had this relationship you know
where the networks but but when it came
to money working for so many years I had
zero so I went back I went back to my
old self so it was like a slap in the
face from from from life and like snap
out of it and
you know and understand that you have to
also lead this side of life so I took it
that way
I took it in a very optimistic way you
know positive way and I didn't really
dwell on that one you know for me like
bankruptcy wasn't a big deal money is
not a big deal for me even though I make
good money yeah what what for me is
about the goal in life I have the
mission yeah you know money's a
byproduct money follows
I don't follow money so for me that was
that wasn't so much meaning about the
pack the family the well-being and all
of that that's that's why I have such a
hard time dealing with because I was
doing everything by the book yeah
you know I was a good follower I was a
good team member you know I work hard
you know I've got great positive energy
but then this thing happened and it
needed to happen now I'm the just the
greatest thing that happened to me
rule number three my personal favorite
believe so I was super poor sometimes we
sometimes we don't right I was sure as
you see I steal short I was a farm boy
and I was a dog boy and the dog boy was
actually a Toretto which a man called
potato it was in something positive it
wasn't something that you should
celebrate it was a kid this smells like
dog the house fleas or ticks that's the
perception so I went through that in my
childhood right because dogs were
following me I didn't know why but dogs
followed me but they so people will go
after me yes because they'll follow me
yeah was that saying mean things to me
then in my our lesson stage though still
follow me I still call it Potrero
I was super sure I'm still short
I was not hip at all and I was not
popular at all then I
came to America and in America I was
called an immigrant which I was right I
was homeless I had place to live so I
lived in the street for two months and
then I speak no English
but it got better it got better because
I stay focused on what I really wanted
for me to happen I wanted to be the best
dog trainer in the world I was 13 years
old when I told my mom mom you think I
can be the best doctor in the world and
she believed that means she says yes you
can be whatever you want and that's
really what we need to attach itself now
what somebody else might see on us you
know all the negativities that they want
to ask they want us to pay attention to
yes I was poor but not from the heart
not from the mind right so so what I did
is I got so what I did is I got hold of
the people that believed in me and thus
that was very important for it for for
and that was very important to me yeah I
don't like to use the word success but I
just like to use the word I accomplished
something because I believed in me
because God believed in me everybody has
a gift I don't think I'm the only human
in the world that has to give everybody
has their own special gift so I just
want to let you know you know that
sometimes when somebody sees something
different in you it's actually a gift
it's a gift that they don't have rule
number four be a good listener you have
to be like marriage counselor financial
adviser everything in this new chef I'm
a good listener I'm a good listener I
think something that I learned from a
dog dog listened well they don't know
what you do for a living they just know
how you live your life so it doesn't
matter how wealthy you are how famous
you are a powerful you think you are and
the dog world who you are is energy so
when you when you become calm and open
minded you get to listen to what people
are saying and what world at a living
rule number five focus on your goals how
did it feel to like have that overnight
success I mean you went from you know
people not necessarily knowing you name
every day to everyone loving you how did
that feel well a everybody knows that is
never an overnight success right you
know
as you know there's you've been doing it
for a while as just now people together
it's a bigger platform right but a thing
it's a labor of being focused you know I
think I I think since I don't do I don't
go outside and experiment with alcohol
and drugs and anything I stay really
focused on the goal you know I want to
rehabilitate dogs I want to train people
I want to educate the world I want to
transform and I think that pays off you
know I think that and also the fact that
I surround myself with people who
believe in that concept you know who you
surround yourself you know who's your
pack is also going to influence your
growth and so I think a lot of the
knowledge that I did that I did I
learned from dogs and apply it to my
business life and to my you know the way
I am the way a parent their way they
relate with people if some people have a
bad energy I rather not be around
because if I can't they can't change I'm
not gonna change them I can change the
dog yeah but I can't change a human
unless the human is willing to do it you
know sir so you have to read all of that
and feel it and and just move on yeah
right away rule number six is become
aware how do we train confidence in
human beings or well first before you
raising the ego before you train
awareness needs to rise you know without
without awareness it is no possibilities
right and then through that awareness
and the human takes responsibility then
when the human take responsibility then
you enter into surrender that's when you
can teach you can teach your mind the
thing knows everything yeah so so fight
flight avoidance surrender you can only
teach the mind of surrender the mind the
fights flight and avoid you can't well
yeah you can so what's the surrender
they're aware once you surrender what
happens as you open up that means you're
willing to follow follow what direction
what direction joga meditation math
whatever you want whatever you want mmm
cuz now you open your mind to absorb
information once you absorb it then you
have to feel it once you feel it you're
clear then you execute feeling and
thought
you can do things without the feeling
it's not gonna look good right yeah the
answer is a perfect example right they
have to feel the music before they
execute the act mmm yeah
singers you know when a singer is
nervous they can sing they can think
they're singing but you know when it
feels good yeah it's a feeling yeah it's
an art use pumps right now try gives you
goosebumps when you feel it when you see
your neck so it connects you to it you
know it touches something deeply inside
of you you know the soul the heart the
bat the body and then the mind the mind
is a flesh is the last thing yeah you
know you're and the mind is a second
thing but really the deep side of you is
this is the is the soul the spirit in
the heart with passion lives that is
really what we have to always connect
yeah and everything else is you know
secondary rule number seven manage your
emotions I think people think I have
this gif I'm a Superman or something and
it's not I'm just like anybody else I'm
just very aware of my emotions
you see I learned to manage my emotions
you know because it's so important to be
honest with yourself one of the one of
the things that I find the most is
people are not honest with themselves
and so you have to work with your
calmness and your assertiveness you know
for example if a dog is very dominant
you can't come with calm energy he's
gonna take over you so you gotta step up
your assertiveness so the dogs see okay
you understand how to play this game
it's like a wah wah West type of thing
rule number eight is give first you were
a young man coming from Mexico and you
had $100 in your posture and a dream of
becoming a dog trainer
tell me about that one be the best oak
tree in the world right so the dream was
big when you start with you dream big
right so that's the good thing about
being poor then you come to a country
where you know opportunities are pretty
much endless
and then I saw the opportunity that
instead of training dogs
I should train people and nobody was
doing that right as an immigrant you
look for empty spaces and that to me was
an empty space so before I even start
charging you know American people I did
it for free I walk dogs for free so
that's what that's when they call me the
Mexican guy who can walk a pack of dogs
so that was my title that's fine yes I'm
Mexican right and and so eventually when
people start trusting me and respecting
what I have to share that we can loyal
to me so trust respect loyalty I first
give that then I start charging ten
dollars per dog rule number nine pursue
greatness the hard work is just
repetition of what you do yeah so long
as you are a working person you're gonna
work hard so that comes that comes with
a formula just that's what you're gonna
do remember people are consistent but
there's sometimes a consistent of doing
the wrong thing so even lazy people are
consistent yeah is it so they work hard
to be lazy yeah so the hard work comes
along just by the fact that you're doing
something every day yeah you know but
it's what you put in your in your goals
what is your mission is it your mission
to help others was it your mission to
help yourself so if you help if your
mission is to help yourself you're not
gonna go too far if your mission is to
help others you're gonna fulfill spirit
hard instincts and mine because that's
when you make a bigger different that to
me is greatness
it's just the grayness to help others
and and for me has been dogs right to
help dogs and then through that I help
humans and then from that it's a
rollercoaster of like so many things I
can do I can create a great world why
not is available and rule number ten the
last one before the bonus clips have fun
so he was like walking around like dirt
oh what's wrong with this dog park was a
dog park
this is pooping his dirt and his penis
squirrels you know it's that's that's a
dog [ __ ]
once he's okay I'm in that relaxed state
then you can walk in first and happy
birthday
it's a it's birthday so I'm gonna make
the best birthday possible froggy it's
his birthday today by the way yeah way
to I know I can believe it by the way
birthday boy you know it's like Nicole
you know you're supposed to have like a
good guy and a bad cat you know and
Nicole has two bad
[Music]
oh no balls McCoy he runs after that
ball he's gonna fight Matt and you know
it well I guess oh my god that was
horrible
is he gonna be okay he's good he's okay
what are you talking about get out of
the dog park just think I need a break
I'm gonna take next time you're gonna
bring wine or something yeah come on
this is the first time I've said a human
to type out but Alice it was a was
necessary I mean I : quarantine time
because Nicole was crapping her son's
birthday
then then Jamie and brown say oh she's
in quarantine hilarious father you know
yeah but but it was more like a cool off
just look at from the front just look
from the outside nothing bad is
happening we take care of your dog and
we hear around he probably likes see
Cesar's here I'm better behaved and hey
hopefully when you leave he's not like
all right with the own picture now as
what a Caesar mask on it has like that
copyrights in the melodic
now I've got some special Caesar bonus
clips for you but before that my
question of the day today are you a dog
person or a cat person I'm a dog person
what are you leaving the comments below
I'm curious to find out thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
you've been very honest about things
that you've experienced personal life
and you talked about a dark period that
you had can you talk a little bit about
that and how you were able to overcome
it I think the more you talk about your
weaknesses them the stronger you become
because you you learn to surrender that
is how you become wise you know I think
the more you suppress what you don't
like about you the more it stays within
yourself so I like to share everything
with people because I think you can
inspire people not just and things that
you are achieved but how you go through
those dark moments of your life you know
a thing is very empowering and as a
father I want my kids to tell anything
that that they don't feel comfortable
with you know instead they're
suppressing that emotion of failing
speak about it you know and somebody is
gonna come and tell you you know what
you're not a failure you're a really
good person that actually is very
important sometimes if somebody comes
and just give you a hug and tell you
you're not that bad don't try to kill
yourself you can help a lot of dogs and
a whole bunch of humans in one episode
neighbors encourage a woman to put her
dog down because the dog showed
aggression even after working with
multiple trainers what did you do with
that book
well most trainers focus on the dog I
focus on the person and you're gonna see
in this and the show that we are
definitely is more people training than
the dog rehabilitation and the
perception that people get by when a dog
attacks them and the fear that they
develop trainers never address that and
so that's why I say I train people and
rehabilitate dogs
so I train them to see what they're
doing wrong everybody focus on what the
dog is doing wrong but the dog can't
speak and say wait a minute
what about what the human is doing
nobody's addressing the human when I
came to America the day December 23rd it
was not a plan it was just a desire I
just didn't question my desire
and then of course the bigger you get
then you need to hire people very smart
people and that's one thing that I teach
my kids as long as you have instincts
you can always hire brains right so I
hire people they're very smart you know
you can hire a lawyer yes yeah so I have
my own lawyers you know so this is a guy
that went to high school only and any
hires all these amazing people that went
to school so then you realize okay what
do I need to do to get there right you
I'm still the pack leader but I say okay
I have to hire this person because this
person understand I'll go raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion and
not one drop of most self-worth depends
on Europe it's something Samia I don't
ever give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details